Good morning gamers!
That's right, Sven is here. It's a beautiful day and we're gonna play Minecraft
That's right Sven is here, it's a beautiful day and we're gonna play Minecraft
How did I become a Minecraft channel and everyone is on board with it if this video gets a million likes we're gonna make it
minecraft month no
I'm kidding or am I? Okay
So first of all, we have a lot to stuff to do today aren't we Sven? AAA I broke my ankle. Sven come on down from there
I've been getting a lot of tips from you guys from on the reddit and one of them was how you
Change to a Swedish banner flag. So we're gonna make that because I made a lot of epic upgrades to the house
Isn't that epic Sven? He's so excited. He's leaving me look at that. That's beautiful his friend
Hey, he doesn't he want to look at me.
Uhm, I accidentally killed his
Boat cows friend. He's like, "I'm not making eye contact with you"
I'm sorry, he had to die
Right Sven?
Sven agrees. Okay. So we're gonna make the banner there's one thing I want to do first is because as you can see
minecraft cow's lot of sound (subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom)(sorry for any mistake)
Let them free. God, it's lagging
There's always something else to do in this game god damn it
Ehhhh- also this series got a shout-out from the god of Minecraft, Notch himself. Thank you Notch for watching
Okay, I'm done. I'm done. Okay, you ga-gamers get to eat now. Here you go. Here you go
You get to eat you get to eat you all get wheat you all get wheat. Just calm down
I know it's very- look there plenty of space but come on space. They're moving
If they had- if they didn't have space they wouldn't be moving. Am I right gamers?
Oh my god - OH!
*laughs*
The game froze, what happened?
NO! NO!
Ooo I almost let them out. Okay, so I have this new system
Double gate gamers. Get out of the way cow double gate.
Ok gamers, You're free
You're free be free. Oh my god
*laughs while being drowned by hundreds of sheep*
Yeah
Oh my god, there's so many of you
Look there's plenty of space. I'm so generous
Now where were the ones I let out I want to kill them look at that beautiful beautiful isn't that beautiful Jeorgen
Jeorgen, I'm speaking to you. Hello. What are you doing? Oh God. Okay. I'll kill the mom
Okay, so there is actually a reason I did all that
Which we'll get to in a second. I just need to organize my inventory. Oh wow
This is look good Felix, and I also built a fence. So Sven can't die from the lava
Don't worry gamer. If Sven dies this playthrough is over
Okay. So the reason why we need
it's because apparently this is
Redstone which activates stuff so if I happen to put down a dynamite
It would activate the dynamite and therefore my house would blow up which is not good in Minecraft
Generally, you want to avoid blowing up your house. That's the pro tip from a veteran gamer. You guys are welcome if we cut the
Sheep. We can make wool which we can make I'm like doing the Swedish accent on ironically at this point chop chip chip chip
Chip chip chip chip chip chip chip chip chip chip chip chicken. Come on, we would all ship ship ship ship
*snip snip snip*
I don't care what Peter says I don't care. You will ship your Winship
(Oh god the lag 3x)
This is what you created PETA if I can't kill them
overpopulation will happen
*sheep casually walks through fence gate*
DON'T ESCAPE
No one escapes if anyone else tries it
That's what I thought. Okay gamers. Now we have wooL. What the Frick are you doing?
(PETA wants to know you location)
That's what you get and that same thing will happen to you one day
If you ever make it out of there wish you won't by the way your doom there for eternity
That's right. Let's also make sure we
pay our respects
Ok, ok gamers. Ok. So now we have a Frick ton of wool
But we need to dye it obviously, I think you use flowers to dye
So we need yeah
We need blue and red yellow obviously and I think I want to make the carpet black, which will you get from?
Why am I talking on ironically about this? And why are you on ironically my cheek? I
Think you get the black from the squids, which I will kill now watch me gamers. Do you swim faster next to dolphins?
I didn't realize that there used to be a million squids here. What the Frick?
Stupid fish ruin my life
But you get fish show me where the squids are. What are you doing Sven? (Sven: I go into boat)
God fuck it
Alright fine fine. You can just take over. Why are you not dead?
Go away.
I will frick you, I'll frick a skeleton. You have bones. I like it!
Oh, yeah, and I caught a dolphin I remember is it still here what?
The dolphin escaped it was down here. I swear
What the hell it why did the dolphin escape -
Why my dolphin not working? Lol? Ok gamers. This is an epic moment is an epic moment
Uh-huh, he agrees
Hello there fellow tradesmen
What are you selling?
Whoa, I need those
God don't spit. I think I need the time but they're so expensive
Shut up Jo - shut - I'm thinking I'm thinking. Okay. How much do they cost?
A bucket of tropical fish dude, I can get a tropical fish I go get a tropical fish be right back
Yeah, man, I can't play this game for two seconds without getting distracted. I have other stuff planned this episode
They wasn't supposed to go this way Oh God get the money get the money
I feel like I just ran into the ice cream truck or some thing
I'm gonna get a goddamn bucket of fish and it's gonna be awesome
bucket of fish bucket of fish bucket of fish bucket of fish bucket of fish
Come on bucket of fish. Oh, he's still here. Thank God. I got a piece so bad weird bucket of fish is waiting
All right bucket of fish man.
I'm sinking as I'm talking... It's really annoying
Can heat cheap gravity I get two bucket of fishes and I'll get these
because I know I can do something with them two bucket of fish and
Now comes the best part the murdering
That's right. Give me back my money. Oh god, they're spitting stop it
Stop it. I didn't do anything. I'm innocent. I am 100% innocent what you just witness was
He hacked your eyes
God, damn it. Why would you spit on me?
Why would you spit on me?
I spit on you I took
Filthy collections. I spit on you and your mother
Jeorgen would never spit on me. Okay, so we're gonna - I'm looking for squids. That's why I came here
stupid squid DDD
Where are you? I will find you squids
Whoa, what is this?
Whoa, this is literally in my house and I've never seen it
Nunnally freaky-deaky, what is this?
Okay, I'm drowing oh god I keep getting distracted we were supposed to make a Swedish banner god dammit
Why is this in my backyard who put this here? I've never seen these blocks before
Allah what there's people down there. Ah
Water people why you live there? However, never noticed this back off water people
All right, what do people got pooped on is there a chest down here or something
*LE GASP* There's a chest down here!
And it's garbage, although there is a treasure map. Am I actually full again? I don't need that. What was I doing?
The flag Felix. Okay, fine. We'll do the flag. All right, Jeorgen you're coming with me. We're gonna pick flowers
It's picking flowers with my best bro Jeorgen time. All right, I need you did. Why can't I go oh
He's on the leash. I'm sorry again.
I was like why is it not working? There you go
Now we can go oh my god nothing like picking flowers with your best bro ain't it. Okay blue is well perfect
Absolutely epic
If we could find red as well, that'd be oh
Yeah. Oh, yeah there again today is our day
It's gaming week
Possibly gaming month Jeorgen. Think about that like minecraft is probably the only gaming where I would actually enjoy picking flowers
But it's so nice, isn't it?
You ruin everything
Don't ever look at Jeorgen again. Okay, we got plenty of red dye. This is perfect. Stop stop in the name of Lord
You don't want to go to my prison. I did you a favor. Oh
It's Enderman. Oh
It's no dammit. I know I'm supposed to kill them because of the ender dragon
But that's all I know the pearls are something. Anyway, I think we have our stuff we'll head back
It's gaming week. I thought they looked cool. Okay, they're like glowing stuff. It's epic carpet
Right, so how do we okay just like that cool
We're making the dye youtube de monetization bought just picked up me saying the bad word. Okay, cool
So now we have red wool. This is epic
Do I know how many I need absolutely not we'll just go buy the floor bing-bam-boom bing bang bong Bing bong
You know, I need your knee when
BIM BAM boom next we make the banner. Okay, so I have to follow the tutorial you guys made
First, we make a banner
And it has to be blue. So we need six of the blue light blue
No dark blue Frick it I need three more. I have two more
Frick it. Oh, yeah, the reason about the shells because I know you can combine it with heart of the sea
That's all I know clearly all I know. Oh, yeah. These can make blue dye. Perfect. Ah
That's not a design flaw. That's a feature. Thank you. One two three
Epic gamer can't you see
I make me a blue flag-ie
epic
Okay, so we do one two, three one two, three and then stick BAM
We got ourself a banner now we have to do
Ruling what is it called?
Ruling. Yes
looming
Okay, we need ship chop your horse. Nope, Oh loom, I told you loom
Okay, we can loom here this will be looming station very epic I need to see well to do looming
Epic we need a yellow dye. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay yellow dye
*quality sound effects*
We got it all gamers Swedish flag time
so we put this here and we put this here and we click the key and
BIM BAM beem beem boom. Boom. Boom go away ugly banner by the way, ugly what banner go away shoosh shoosh
Banner, uhhh
There it is. Okay, it's gone and it's gone and boom
Yea-yah
*happy noises*
Oh, that's epic, I love it that's cool.
Oh God, I should have gone with you. I should have done yellow here that oh my god. I got it. Alright gamers
Then no I did not just do with a diamond pickaxe. Don't worry about it. You guys have to worry about every detail
Whatever I use a shovel Bing bong Bing Bing bong. Damn. This looks good
Damn, that looks good
Okay. Alright, I
Think we should do blue here actually, this is what minecraft is all about color coordinating
something only gamers will understand
Bing-bam-boom
Yeah, it's got to be like that gamers. We got to make the bed match of course and Sven's sleeping pad
Throw my old bed in the fire. No big deal
Man
Dark wood bed that might be epic
Alright, there it is. I'll hide when you hold that. It's so tiny and then BAM beautiful
Let's not forget about Sven's sitting cushion bean bomb
Cute! If Sven leave the boat? You could actually enjoy it
So the reason I kept this is cos it's a burek and it's a very Swedish famous tree, I think
Maybe not. I think every country has a killer. Okay. Well, whatever gamer. Oh, right. I forgot about my bucket of fish
There's too much happening in this game I can't keep up
Where should I keep my bucket of fish?
Maybe here in the little pond. There you go bucket of fish
All right. I'll find a better use for you later. Oh god, don't tell me this runs out in the water. No, it isn't I
Don't I don't trust you guys
Now now now now but now tropical tropical tropical tropical tropical
No, I punched a fish. I'm so sorry. What do you have the one go come back here you tropical son of a snake
I pay good money for you fish. I will do with you as I please
All Right, I won't go here for now. Okay, so if you thought that was it that was not it, okay
we have many epic things to do because
I'm so obsessed Jesus Christ
AAAAAA
They're attack-onizing (?)
They set up a trap
You go to sleep go to sleep go to sleep it's really cool Easter egg
Just click on the bed just click on the bed ha ha he did it idiot a pig on top
Ok, so I'm a I figured out since you guys told me
But there's eight blocks in the narrowed around in
IRL that I can make a portal to new places that I want to go to
I know IQ 5,000 as long as I don't get attacked here. We should be alright, so we have this portal which goes to
*portal sounds*
Epic place. Hello. Thanks for welcoming me
So I found this city. I never explored it yet, but it looks so cool. They got like
houses in the mountains and
They are all depressed
It's awesome. They're just like me. We're totally fitting in. Hello
Okay
Hippity-hoppity your money is my property as we say in sweden. This is why they depress everyone's taking this stuff. I didn't do anything
I swear I didn't do anything. All right, what else more money?
It's poor people. Oh poor people. Don't worry if you're matter, but if you're mad at me
Oh, they have Jeorgen. Is there no one to trade here. There's really then there's no reason for me to
Build that portal thing, but I spent so long
Hello, does anyone that want to trade they're all just a bunch of poor people oh my god
It's a tiny alcohol - a creepy notch would not have come up with us. Not saying I don't like them all I'm saying
It's not should not have made them. All right, what about the ones in the mountain? Maybe that's where the epicness?
You guys do anything any day all day pop-pop. Yep
Hippity-hop Vinny. Hey, look I have the bucket. I don't have the bucket. All right you win this time cat?
You win this time. Look how cute they designed it that ones have a hat. Maybe that one can trade. Hello hat man. Ow
Broke my leg. It's fine hat man hat man trades wheat! I have so much wheat. I'm gonna be rich
Okay, the portal was worth it. There's one thing I thought about
Because I always have to look for them. Right is it mean if I lock them in?
So I don't have to look for them all the time, right?
Okay, cool. So now I'll find him easier more easily
Perfect. You just stay there epic. All right, let's check the top. Hippity hoppity Hippity hoppity
Whoa. All right
Better not be a trap
Okay
Flowers for Joergen. It's actually a nice house
Like I would like to live here. Maybe we'll will emigrate with Jeorgen one day to a new place
All right
We're going to sleep because there's another thing around here that I have never seen before and that is my gamers
We'll get to it in a sec
It's got oh, it's a is that a church does I mean that there's a god of Minecraft. Of course. There's
Notch must be inside here
Notch-ie. Hello? What is this? Brewing stand?
They got colored gLaSs?
What? (yOu NEvEr pLayED tubEr SimULATOR?)
They got torches. This is awesome. The city's cool. I like this city Oh epic I want to
Lock him in as well actually when I just dig underneath him. No stop
Don't escape. There you go. Enjoy enjoy the whole since but this here so we find you enjoy the whole have fun
I'll trade with you later
I'll let you out if you trade with me
hippity hop with a hello Jeorgens
Here you go have Apple
There you go. Enjoy. See they have a road and stuff
It's awesome as gamers know whenever there's a pretty utopia. There are other people that want to take part of it
Where is it? There? It is. See they have the this is I never seen this
But it's an enemy camp look at them. So we're gonna go absolute sicko mode right now
I'm gonna set up a little
Defense maybe here. Oh
God, they're coming
Don't shoot don't shoot you will never get past my defenses. AAA.  Frick
*most intense minecraft battle*
How can you shoot backwards? Oh, they keep coming
Wow, ok easy. There's a lot more of them though
Come on gamers
Like I just try to 360
This is gonna take all day, I should just go for it
Sicko mode sicko mode. Oh you're charging
Oh the cactus ha ha gaming week gaming week. I'll kill them all
I don't care what it takes
You're all gonna die
Gaming week
Too slow - OW ok all right
If you guys get along then maybe you can kill me but you can't because you suck
Yeah
Should we blow it up. Do I have TNT I'm tempted to just go back and get oh
God there's more this must be the leader
Where you from Lidl?
Dude he dropped the crossbow. I never had them. Look at me. Haha. Oh, I hear more of them
I think they respawn
Okay, we've got it we've had our advance our way inside alright pirates bring your A game
Or your B game actually don't think no think just kill bye. Oh
Whoa, Bottle o' enchanting. What is that? Okay. I'll take a game. Oh damn they all respawn
Oopsie, I think they're angry. Can I blow up their place though? I legit want to oh, he's getting dangerous. Oh, oh, oh
Time to bounce later gamer
Home Sweden home
okay, so I
Have all this rotten flesh. I knew I hain't knew saving up all this useless stuff. What's gonna be worth it? I
Just realized I googled how to make dynamite
FBI is gonna find me guys
oopsie gunpowder, which I have
Oh my god. Oh my god
No wonder my game is lagging
All right. I just needed to do a dynamite test. So I think if I remember you could use redstone
that's like a fuse do I lit it or
Hmm
Maybe I can is it one of these the torch and I hit it with the torch Oh
Yep
Okay
Wait what what is happening?
Read I think I'll read a comment about this I didn't think it would happen. Oh god guys were raided what is happening?
Is it hard? I think people said it was hard. You guys will help me, right?
Now they're all freaking out. They don't want to trade with me now
Frick I'm not ready for this. I'm ready to pull up. Oh, there they are. There they are
Oh, wow, stone guy is killing it Duke
Don't worry guys. Don't worry eye protection. Oh, sorry. I almost hit him
Don't kill the hat man
Get out of the bed
Did it
Wait what it continues? Oh
God charge my crossbows. Oh god, they mean business chief says, oh my god, dude
They got axe people. Oh my god. Oh my god. I'm dead. There's only one way out. This is not even my city
oh god, I
Swear I had so much food God the iron golem is not helping. Well, thank God. I protected them
Yeah, what'd I say you thought it was cruel bring it it's gone that deuces Lauda Tammy
It's a leader
Bring it
Thank God the baby made it
I'll barricade him. So no one can kill the child. Oh
My god, he's alive thank God. All right. Goodbye the last oh
God it's another raid. I can't deal with this
We're gonna have to get the big guns out. Oh, they're coming from the other side. Holy freaky Mickey. What is that? Oh,
It's gonna have to go boom
Whoa, whoa relax
I'm not I didn't sign up for this. I did not sign up for this. I did not sign up for this
This is not my city. This is not my battle. No one said anything about giant freaking bulldozers. Just want me to
Come on Raiders. Oh, it's only the bulldozers are left. Oh god, how how how
Okay range range battle
Oh
God it sees me
I'm sorry. Sorry poori
Oh god, it's got a lot of help
And I'm gamers a
Holter. Oh, this is bad. Jeorgen where are you?
AAAAAAAAA
I'm out of arrows freaky. Okay. I have a gamer plan. I have a gamer plan Oh
God
Gamer oh
Wow, you're really angry, aren't you?
Ah
Oh my god, yeah. Oh
My god Oh
Ooooh enchanted
Oh he died
God it keeps going I can't do more they got wizards and stuff this time. I'm sorry wizard
Actually gonna die how long does his last how do I cure poison?
This is the most intense battle I have ever done in my life
NOOOO
Damn it
Why am I here? Oh because I slept in the bed. Oh my god. I'm an idiot or a genius question mark
Freaking one shot at me dude. Oh
My god, that's where it went Oh
No
Are you kidding me? These freaker's are correct. They're crazy. They one shot you go. Oh
he went through two that's
Kidding me my stuff is right there
Jesus Christ
Luckily I do remember the way home. It's just very far
Oh
Boy, what a day. It's not over yet. The battle is still on. All right, I have to make so much new stuff. Oh
God if only the pigs could help me. Okay, they should be over there. Oh my god. They are look at that butt, dude
Okay, maybe I can push him off
You kidding me and I respawn here because I forgot to sleep
Oh my god, yes. Yes
Ye-he-he-essss
That's the best thing that could ever happen. Oh no, I'm so out of logs, dude
He's blowing up my bridge
D I E
Want my stuff back
Yes
No another I can't do another I'm done
How long this is keep going? Oh
My god what they're writing them now
They really want they really want blood
I'll give them that
This is a bit more than I bargained for
Jesus Lord
It's over Anakin I have the high ground
Don't do it we can be friends don't shoot
*Intense focus*
If I stand really low
He shoots himself. Yes. Yes
Gaming I did it. I did it
Oh
Free you're free to go you're free to live. You're free to you're free. I save your people. Ow
The child Oh No, well Jeorgen is - Jeorgens are okay
What the Frick is this
I'm fun in hell. What the Frick?
And we're back home
very
Epic that's it for me for now smash like for more minecraft, and I'll see you guys next time
Bye!
What you never played 'tuber simulator???
You know, it's fun, right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is available for free and that's a great price